alles für absoluten blödsinn volkswagen
rassismus über die absicht zu
unterstellen
weiter zu unterstützen wer das sagt er
weiß nicht was folgsam können
unternehmen ist und das ist gerade wegen
seiner vergangenheit in der nazi zeit zu
einem der unternehmen gehört da die als
erste sehr umfangreich ihre verstrickung
in das sms system offengelegt hat die
sehr viel tun zum beispiel schicken sie
jedes jahr junge auszubildende in die
gedenkstätte des ehemaligen
konzentrationslagers nach auschwitz
arbeiten dort mit
um diese gedenkstätte zu erhalten so
volkswagen des rassismus und des
rechtsradikalismus zu verdächtigen kann
nur sagen gute besserung das quatsch